xavier bertrand bonsoir voir beaucoup de
questions concrètes mais d'abord je
dirais que ce décret porte votre nom
c'est dire l'importance que vous y
attachez donc il fallait accélérer il
fallait aller plus vite il fallait
mettre le turbo
alors que la mission parlementaire elle
pensait qu'ils allaient le faire avec un
thème pour moi rapide
c'est une grande avancée de santé
publique qui étaient décidées à la fois
pour protéger la santé de tous non
fumeurs comme fumeurs mais aussi pour
mobiliser l'ensemble de la société il ya
deux chiffres qu'on ne peut pas oublier
soixante mille personnes meurent du
tabac parce qu'elle fume mais près de
6000 morts du tabac alors qu'elle ne
fume pas si le tabagisme passif
nous savons quelle est cette réalité n'y
a pas de fatalité et on peut réussir
comme sur la sécurité routière
il a eu la volonté du président de la
république avec le plan cancer et
l'engagement aussi du premier ministre
sur ce dossier la fin de la cohabitation
des fumeurs et des non fumeurs
publication forcé fumeurs non fumeurs
qui est maintenant est terminée alors si
vous voulez on va être très concret dans
la pratique au travail au bureau dans
les entreprises dans les écoles dans les
collèges c'est la tolérance zéro à
partir du 1er février plus de 25
millions de français vont voir les
choses changer
il n'y aura plus de tabac sur les lieux
publics cette interdiction est clair il
n'y aura plus d'espacés fumeurs alors
par exemple dans les entreprises et ça
concerne le temps de salariés est ce
qu'il y aura un endroit on devra fumée
est ce qu'on pourra aller que sur le
trottoir sera le trottoir ou
l'abstinence ou est ce qu'il y aura ces
fameux fumoir l'entrepreneur pourra
avoir cet espace fumeur fermé s'ils
respectent les nouvelles normes que nous
allons mettre en place dans le décret
qui sera publié avant la fin du mois de
novembre
c'est à dire qu'il faudra des critères
très précis pour l'extraction de la
fumée encore une fois pour protéger la
santé de tous mais attention dans les
hôpitaux comme dans les écoles les
collèges les lycées
il n'y aura pas de ce type d' espaces
nous avons fait le choix que dans ceux
là qui dépendent de la responsabilité de
l'état
il n'y aura pas ce type d' espaces
fumeurs ont parlé de ces fumoirs avec
des normes très strictes
on a l'impression qu'il ya un certain
flou qui entoure finalement ces fumoirs
c'est ce que disent alors on y reviendra
mais les professionnels de la
restauration des hôtels y aura aucun
flou dans le décret parce que nous avons
pris le temps de la concertation nous
avons interrogé les uns les autres pour
aller dans le détail et nous avons bien
tiré les leçons aussi de ce qui s'est
passé avec la loi evin la loi était
générale mais le décret pris enfin 92
lui n'allait pas dans le détail
nous nous avons tiré tout
leçons de ce qui s'est passé alors pour
les fumeurs qui souhaitent arrêter est
ce que la sécu va prendre en charge le
sevrage est à quelle façon oui parce que
nous ne voulons pas seulement avoir
cette décision d'interdiction mais nous
voulons faire ce qui n'a pas été fait
ailleurs aller plus loin c'est à dire
que nous allons permettre de doubler le
nombre de personnes qui ont recours à
des patchs à des gommes ou à des
médicaments pour arrêter de fumer nous
allons passer de 600 mille à un million
deux cent mille personnes
nous allons aussi doubler les
consultations de tabacologie parce que
certaines personnes qui veulent arrêter
de fumer c'est pas facile d'arrêter de
fumer ont besoin d'un soutien et nous
allons aussi aider davantage les
associations sécurité sociale un
engagement de près de 100 millions
d'euros par an que nous voulons faire de
façon à pouvoir accompagner les fumeurs
et profiter encore une fois de ce déclic
provoqué par cette décision
pour justement gagner cette victoire
contre le tabac alors les professionnels
à partir de 2008 donc en sursis mais ils
devront donc se conformer à cette loi
anti tabac
on l'a vu dans le reportage il parle
d'une mesure annoncée avant l'élection
présidentielle
application après 2007 est ce que ça
veut dire qu'on va être sur le terrain
politique
non il ya plus important que la
politique et que les élections il y à la
santé publique j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
de ces deux chiffres
soixante mille près de 6000 ça s'impose
à tout le monde et c'est plus important
que les résultats électoraux
je crois en plus que c'est une mesure
qui est très attendue parce qu'on parle
aussi de la santé publique je vous livre
est juste une anecdote en allant d'un
resteront l'autre jour le responsable du
restaurant le nom d si oui ou non nous
allions prendre cette décision je dis
pourquoi il dit parce que j'ai passé
l'autre jour une radio des poumons
le médecin en voyant la radio me dit
vous êtes fumeur vous le patron du
restaurant dit non j'ai arrêté voilà
trente ans a alors vous devez dans la
restauration
ça m'a marqué ce qui montre bien que les
bières pour mais que la responsabilité
politique qui est la nôtre qui est celle
de dominique de villepin nous a conduit
à ne pas attendre après les élections
pour engager les choses et de commencer
dès le 1er février 2007
probablement que le débat ne fait que
commencer merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions